I used to get a bicycle and might get a
bicycle I was mean steal one out of
somebody's yard and sometime it could be
anybody's bicycle I'd take that sucker
and I bike over to my girl's house I had
this little you know beautiful white
girl I was seeing that she was you know
there you know that rubenesque a little
bad girl you know and we go over there
and I sneak up in her room and it had a
cat they had this grey cat I had to
sneak past this little [ __ ] bra
and he was always trying to start
something with me you know like he like
we had met in a previous life and I'd
done something wrong to him you know
like maybe like a couple hundred years
ago he'd been you know was eating a
piece of fish or something by a river
and I came up and stole that carp out of
his hand and so you know now he's out
here he's trying to get back at me
so whenever I go into this girl's house
I sneak into the laundry room
they had a door to the outside you go
into the laundry room and come into the
kitchen
well that cat this little grey hitter he
would hide in there they had all these
towels and you know dryer sheets and
stacks of all kind of stuff or whatever
in the laundry room so and it was pitch
black and I couldn't cut the light on
because you're worried you know you
don't want like going out under the door
into the kitchen what if the moms
walking down the hall or whatever you
know I couldn't have the family see that
I was sneaking in so I've get in that
laundry room and it dude it was like the
laundry was about 9 or 10 feet long to
that from one door to the next door and
it was just a gauntlet bra and every
time like clockwork that little gray
[ __ ] come flying off on one of
the top ropes like Jimmy Superfly Snuka
and just do that for leg drop on me yeah
I mean just and then it was on boy it
was on and you couldn't even see us it
was just this dark fiasco and then you
know I'd make it up to her room and then
and then the cool thing was so then I'd
get into the kitchen finally get away
from that little mom you know a little
deal and I'd then I have to sneak up to
her room
um and the stairs went over her parents
bedroom so you had like real stop step
on the sides of the stairs that was a
trick don't step out in the middle of
the [ __ ] stairs like somebody that
never broken anybody's housing before
step on the side of them steps you know
so it's really where the wood is strong
and so it doesn't make any sound you get
up to the top and then go sneaking old
girl's bed thank you guys for checking
out this clip and if you want to see
another clip and you can look at this
clip or this clip either one of these so
did you pick one or he's still just
watching me do this cuz this is alarming